this is the theme the deegeu bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be on
TV welcome back to the Deen show today
we're going to be talking about the
family keeping it together preventing it
from breaking apart my guest who's
coming on a second
Imam was the VA's aide who's the author
of the lies about Muhammad he is also an
imam in new jersey has a lot of
experience dealing with families who
have these issues husband and wife
coming together but having a hard time
staying together some know their roles
some don't and some just don't want to
know and we want everybody to know and
to implement what the creator is told
him to implement so we can live a more
fruitful productive life and we can have
success in this life success and
paradise which is the ultimate
destination and goal in the next we'll
be right back to talk about the family
keeping it together here on the Dean
show
this is the thing
assalamu alaikum peace deal America
how are you handling the lies about
Mohammed you're the author of it yes and
you have a lot of experience you've been
an imam for how long about eight nine
years then eight nine years so in our
last show people can go to the Deen show
calm and we discussed family business
family planning how to keep the homes
together rather than breaking it because
you will suffer the kids will suffer so
we really want to talk more about this
issue and give some practical tips
examples of people who did the wrong
thing not the right thing and where they
are today how that affected them so can
you just bring us up to speed on some of
the things that we talked about in the
previous episode and people can go back
to the Deen show calm to see that common
one is the level of gratefulness to the
marriage some husbands and some wives
thinks that the qualities that they have
from their marriage is a birth given
right and we focus only on the negative
things till it mushrooms to into a
divorce and the husband or the wife
would go seek another marriage and in
that other marriage whatever they had
thought is given them for granted is
actually not even there for example the
husband used to complain and you know I
witness this that wife does not take
care of herself she does not put that
enough makeup and so on so forth maybe
the wife was not you know paying
attention to that much even though we
give her the advice and because she took
care of his household and his children
like no one else could and he decided
you know I won the horse this a lot of
the temptations out there I want a
beautiful woman that does not make me
look he did not pay attention to the
grateful and be grateful for the good
qualities that his wife was providing he
looked for the real beautiful one the
high-maintenance beautiful wife she was
Muslim too he got married
she provided zero of the other things
that he took for granted she did not
cook she don't want to have children
tell you no certain time and she had
children she wanted to put conditions
that she would buy you know hire enough
nannies and so on and so forth and he
would wish for one day of the quality of
life that he had with his other wife and
that was a punishment from allah
subhanaw taala because you need to be
grateful first for what you have before
you ask for more and the same thing
applies vice versa two wives to the
husband works hard he provides he takes
care of her but maybe because of that
hard work he does not have enough time
to spend with the wife as much as she
likes
but for that little thing she want to
blow up the entire marriage and she does
she now goes with a husband that yes you
know spends more time with her but does
not provide and actually want her to go
out there and work because we could not
afford what we have you know from the
beginning that I and so on and so forth
and the quality is that the other
husband was providing is gone and now
she does not care actually she won
lesser time with the second husband
altogether why she was not grateful to
the blessings of allah subhanaw taala
that he gave her and lots of analysis
what Intel do not annoy Lateran in the
settlement if you count the blessings of
allah subhanaw taala you will not be
able to there countless but people are
ungrateful another example is the
influence the outside influence for
example you know this is a recent one
business owner millionaire you know any
dream husband for any wife and she had a
college degree
Allah saponify had blessed a couple with
two beautiful babies the mother comes in
well I did not send you to college and
had all these cost and all that you know
work and care for you so you can sit
home buts at home you are caring for
your own babies and what you need to
work for we work to compensate our hours
and hard work for money if Allah that
lists you with that money in even plenty
and in abundance with with your husband
why do you want to go out there and work
for $40,000 a year and your hospitals a
millionaire leaving your two babies and
the mother influenced and you know again
was not grateful for the case what
happened divorce now she's not married
very hard for her to get married with
two babies
if you want to work now well go work and
spend the entire income on babysitting
the kids and so on and so forth this is
a live example yes yes so the husband
was it was a millionaire yes and now you
mentioned the outside influence this is
where it happened the mother-in-law was
coming in yes and to your surprise
sometimes the influence of the
mother-in-law or the father-in-law is -
how would I say it air a grievance that
they had in their own personal life hmm
so sometimes the mother was really
oppressed by an oppressive husband who
really oppressed her and wasn't just
with her so she wanna retaliate
subconsciously maybe not intentionally
subconsciously by making her daughter
the dominant force in the household and
really belittling the man as if he is
you know a doormat or something and no
real man would accept that so what
happens divorce and who's the victim her
own daughter and the children and the
daughter is the one to blame your mother
is your mother but your mother had her
own house and her own life to apply her
own ideology and her own manners in it
you are responsible for your own
household not your mother so that was
her fault bringing that influence and
this brings me to a point where yes
parents are sacred in Islam it's a loss
of paradises messenger and they're doing
well by parents but doing well by
parents is not something that
contradicts the other Hallel of having a
good husband having a good life obeying
the husband obeying the guidelines of
allah subhanaw taala
when it comes to your role as a spouse
anyone household and you'll never find
in this land a Hallel that contradicts
another Hallett it's all complimentary
it's all you know a whole harmonized
structure so when people bring these
contradictions
they are bringing outside influences
that victimizes their their own selves
and their own children and their own
marriage in the process now just to
bring some people up to speed who didn't
see the last show we did that okay and
people we encourage to really know your
role and you're right so the man has to
provide for the household he has to take
care of the WYD be kind to her merciful
I heard you quoted Sam Hardy for the
Prophet SAW said the best of
you are those who are best to their
family that are wise and the best so to
try to be the best to your wife and not
to be a dictator consult with your wife
but after now the president the CEO the
someone had to lead the house to Allah
the creator put the man in charge so
once he makes a decision he consults
with his Lord he does his - how to
praise and he feels this is the right
thing the woman as we said earlier she
has to obey the husband I still be the
husband and if she has a different
opinion she needs to voice that and
States and you know what it's not
opinions as different personalities
opinion that adheres also to the benefit
of Islamic law that we talk about so
you're not gonna fight if you abide by
the law for loss of another wife and
that's where your pinion is formulated
according to and the same way that your
husband that rules and actually takes
takes care of the household based on
Islamic law you're not gonna find any
contradiction life would be so easy yeah
now some people just before we go to a
break some people when you say the word
obey all right you know cuz again the
Jerry print and Springer society you
ain't gonna tell me what to do so it's a
obey I know pain nobody you ain't my
master so what do we mean when we say
obey this is lay a las upon out that
obey the crater and the the husband is
applying the laws and the guidelines of
allah subhanaw taala
and you obeying allah subhanaw taala in
the form of your husband if your husband
asked you to steal cheat not pray do
something wrong
there's no obedient or baby because
there's no obedience anyone in this
event of an attack yeah so you're
actually obeying allah subhanaw taala
but you're not married to allah subhanaw
taala god forbid you married to your
husband that's where you show the
obedience the loss of paradise to him a
child it's a break we'll be right back
with more here Indonesia
Janina he did you say that you do not
believe in Jesus you have stepped
outside of this name you can not be a
Muslim is that ended our faith to
believe in and love Jesus Christ why is
it then when it comes to one of the most
important decisions in life he literally
abused ourselves it's not that the main
thing we're looking for is to see what
type of money he has so that he can
treat my daughter like a princess it's
not about
back here on the Dean show and we're
discussing family keeping it together we
don't want it to fall apart so knowing
your roles knowing your responsibilities
and then living up to it yes so tell us
now giving us some more examples we know
that Islam is the perfect way of life
it's not man-made all the evidence
points to this being from the one who is
the most loving merciful kind the
creator of the heavens there he's the
most just he knows best so at the end of
the day when your husband tells you
honey listen if we're gonna fight this
fight in a polite way
honey let's do it this way because I
feel it's best so the woman should do
what jihad a struggle maybe she's coming
from jihad Leah saying for the man some
so you know she's been watching a lot of
juries but she left all it alone now and
she wants to be a good woman a good
Muslim woman she's got a because
sometimes that inside you is just wants
to lash out you just want to you know
your emotions get high
you got to submit I would I'll give you
a real example yeah actually it's a
member of my family yeah lady that is
really pious she was fixing a nice meal
to her husband was a really pious man
and he was sitting down waiting for her
to finish sitting up the table and you
know there was an article in the
newspaper that actually attracted him
and he was taken by it and his wife kept
calling him come to the dinner County
dinner come to the night that she really
got mad and then she went grabbed a
newspaper and tore it apart she was
really mad and the advice from promise I
never get mad never get mad never get
mad when a man came to him and said I'm
simple-minded I do not know how to put
all this lemon on my head tell me
something they ever follow and Charlotte
get into Jannah you don't get mad and
repeated three times what would the
husband do look at the manners of Islam
because the good Muslim he waited till
she calmed down and the first thing that
he did he went to the ground and picked
up the pieces of the newspaper and
Scotch taped him together in and did it
in nice plight we would not even look at
her she said to me
that I'd rather that somebody with me or
beat me up to death
then the pain that I felt of his
politeness in as an answer to how rude I
was and this is how marriages the
tolerance and the politeness happens but
we want to touch upon a very important
point which is don't buy a broken car
yeah a really bad car and then bring the
best mechanic in the world to fix it and
call that a good marriage a good
marriage start with how to pick up the
good wife and the good husband and
promise SNM give us the ultimate
guidance of that the one with the Dean
the man with the Dean mean Dean always
means in the language of promises Salaam
the good manners not just one who
memorized the Quran or have the longest
beard a man who practically proves his
Islam by dealing with people with the
marriage of Islam and the manners of the
Prophet that's how he choose a husband
how to choose a wife from Moses enemies
famous hadith Tom Calma a woman is
pursued for marriage for for her beauty
her money her social status or her Dean
and Dean again hair manners from
hommerson advice follow for Baudette
Dini Terabithia death take the one with
the Dean otherwise you would regret it
and we all know as husbands the most
beautiful woman that won one of the more
money and the family or whatever you
would marry her two weeks three weeks
tops for whatever the reason and they
become normal what last is the quality
of her character her manners is a Muslim
moment her Dean choose the one with the
Dean choose the one that adheres to the
lawful loss of Hanna and obeys allah
subhanaw taala
in you and then the marriage would be an
easy sale you have the window to bad
picking the husband that way and pick
him go out that way that's the
foundation of a marriage that lasts when
it gives some more practical examples
you're living with that person and you
know what Shaitaan he wants to break the
home this is one of the things that he
loves is to dividing husband and wife
so when jealousy comes in this or
bad attitude or some of these other
things that kind of will end up making a
husband angry with his wife or a wife
angry with the husband give some some
practical advice like how we don't let
that escalate
and that gets a very important point the
overwhelming majority especially of the
wives and I would let our sisters pay
attention to that is that the husband
does something that they don't like or
hate and you don't express that to the
husband and the husband thinks you know
what I know this is wrong but that's
okay with her so no problem next time
I'll let it out the same way and then he
keeps doing bad hateful thing and
sometimes even in a worse way and she
does not still express it then it comes
to a point where I see in marriages that
last is for 14 15 years with four
children and the wife comes to a point
that's it no matter what you do divorce
no way back and we spent I spent a year
and a half of the family a year and a
half doing you know circus work not just
a zani man doing everything that he can
possibly imagine try to put the family
together and she had so much built up of
anger of all that residual over the
years and the husband told me innocently
and I believed him I didn't know that
she didn't like that talk about
communication yes express in a nice
polite way after the dust settles I
don't like that same thing sometimes
diffuses the whole thing saying no I
don't want I don't like to do this they
would no matter what kind of man it is
he would think twice before doing it
again never mind third time never keep
doing it till the woman explodes and
she's a good sister and he was a good
husband but communication obeying the
husband is something and communicating
with the husband is a different thing
and the same thing husbands you know and
and and this is harder for the husband
if the wife is not communicating do not
take advantage of you know
when a wife is you know obedient and
nice and does not want to start fights
and so and so far thank a lot for that
do not abuse it yeah and as we know the
wisdom a lot of our moms are told a
wisdom is what I'm a believer seeks and
when he finds it he is most deserving
with al-hikmah doll atonement nmos you
do ha it was a tie for half of it if you
wife is like that then listen to the
common wisdom even the street what do
you abuse is what do you lose yeah tell
us now you mentioned in the previous
show where the woman being and letting
out more of these women quality the
softness the man being a man but
sometimes the roles get reversed and the
woman you have like sometimes two men in
the house and no man likes another man
in the house
how important is it like sticking to
your nature and not being one who's
taking the man's role the man figure
this is the best quality the female can
enjoy is it her being a true female
versus a real man a real man will demand
quality and the way that a man feels his
manhood and and enjoys and have pleasure
with it is with a true female yeah the
more female she is the more man he is
and the more identified that quality the
more they both is going to enjoy their
life a lot so Hanna created it to each
one to complement each other actually
I'm an engineer by education and
actually the electric current that
electric current that everything around
you works with how does it work a
positive and a negative and because of
the potential difference that way we
call it engineering the current moves
from the positive to the negative
and by that circulation life works so
the thing that the positive means from
the negative and the things that the
negative means from the positive that's
what create the current of life that way
I mode so you know if a man agrees to be
a lesser man in his household
that's lesser of calling fly for him as
a man and the more mannish a woman
become even not in behavior or
physically but just by the way that she
treats her husband the quality of life
is gone and then the marriage is you
know well the roommates and roommates
can change mates left and right here why
stick to this roommate you have some
brothers who also bring up the the whip
of the tongue sometimes a it can happen
for the man too but sometimes the woman
will whip the husband with the tongue
you know what I mean by the tongue and
it really gets out of hand how do we
control this tongue actually one of the
one of the things the problems our son
warned about Muslim to jabber one of the
greatest companions of our moms as
silent as the question innocently and
you can tell and it's very rare in the
real problem almost asylum that he can
send some anger there from Mom's the son
was very patient he asked them are we
gonna be judged for what we say from
home systems it's like Eli Tomac may
your mother lose you and this is very
rare the promise of that isn't it
what pours people on
their faces into Hellfire is the harvest
of their tongues a tongue yes from my
master Simon came to him and said o
prophet guarantee me paradise problem
Hassidim said guarantee me what's
between your lips and between your
thighs you know implying do you know
adultery I would guarantee you paradise
and if you think about it two thirds of
the way to paradise is the tongue and a
lot of people do not realize that one
word that you see in a moment of anger
can devastate someone's character can
devastate someone's personal stamina and
confidence in their selves oh you're
ugly you're this you that we have to be
careful that yes we say things the
moments of anger but do not you know use
that whip of a tongue especially when
the woman challenges the manhood of the
man oh you're not men enough to do this
if you man enough divorce me if you do
and these challenges that we put powers
in stupidity of anger and anger as per
the definition for mamas SLM is when the
Shaitaan is writing you when you allow
yourself to get angry you're not holding
the steering wheel if your life anymore
it's the devil and the devil does not
want to hurt you the devil want to put
you in Hellfire he doesn't want it
halfway
that's why promise excellent and I'll
get angry if you get angry sit down
if you cannot sit down lie down the
first thing to defeat anger with is just
make a pollution why what's happening is
fire from the devil and you put it off
by the word of a pollution say all the
blame is Shaitaan regime and so on and
so forth so avoid these moments of anger
choose your wife correctly have
tolerance be grateful for you have
already because you never know the
beautiful women outside that looks so
nice and fancy you don't know how
trustworthy they are how honest they are
how protective they are are they going
to be good mothers or not one of the
good things in Islam and I said it
before is that allah subhanaw taala
praying on time and then doing with my
parents the second best thing that
muslim can do is doing well by parents
and we know something that is called a
holiday in which anyone should have
waited any cost which is you're not
doing well by your parents that's a very
big sin and a big loss but there's also
a pope up there meaning that you're not
doing well by your sons and daughters
what was the definition of that a woman
that is not a good Muslim that does not
have a good reputation that might have a
deviated behavior and just for her looks
whatever circumstances you just get
married to her and now we will force
your son from her or daughter from her
to have a mother with that bad
reputation with that bad mannerism and
by that you belittle and took and
devastated the rights of your own son
and daughter upon you when you choose
that mother to be their mother that
woman to be their mother just this is
such a vast topic so I'm just closing a
few important points the do's and don'ts
in the last two minutes that we have you
said outside influence it should be
limited to who like you know the wife
should she be going back to the month
said to her mother the the son going
here and then you know the whole
community coming in and giving their
opinion what they think is right but
actually making it worse who should they
go to who should they not go to to make
this work
it's up the responsibility of marriage
is the responsibility of the man and the
woman the husband and wife they are
allowed in the matter of fact they are
persuaded and encouraged to go seek
advice but give the advice about the
specifics of your house common advice do
not tell the secrets of your household
to people who are close by so they can
influence and make a small problem a
bigger problem seek knowledge from
people you don't know
read asked as she asked a scholar
without even stating your name and find
out what is the right thing to do about
that situation what to do with your
husband do not get people even the
closest people to get involved with that
much details you are responsible they're
not you're the one who's gonna carry the
burden and the responsibility if it
works or not they're not and I don't
know any mother that compensated a good
wife for a good husband I don't know any
father who compensated a good son for
his good wife it never happened and I
will never happen and at the end of the
day you're the one to blame you carry
the responsibility so take care of your
own problems so so so you're your
beloved sibling or your mother can
actually at the end do more harm than
good many cases that happened yeah many
cases that even though they love you
they have good intention and and and I
have this final example a mother that
actually the her son in law who was a
laborer he was not professional works
about twelve hours a day
had the courtesy to invite her to live
with him and his kids and the man worked
like a mule all day to provide for the
family and he would kill himself to
provide for everything of them whenever
they get invited to some of the
relatives who are professionals who have
better queries and better jobs that her
daughter his wife does not qualify to
that why because she's not that educated
either she would make sure that she tell
oh I feel sorry for you look at the cars
they have the houses they have the
furniture they have why you accept that
and she kept belittling the man so much
that the woman said I have to get a
divorce my life is being wasted now
she's on food stamps and her mother just
left her to live with her own other son
Wow
good to be the mother thought that she's
doing a good thing but you know again
who was carrying the the the the the
blame and the responsibility and the
burden at the end of the day it's you
it's you so turn it back to a law and
his messenger live life according to a
laws will not your desires consult with
physicians scholars in Islam and try to
live and not because you love me as a
friend or a mother or anything you know
my mother loved me more like anything in
the world but when I had a need of
surgery I would not go to her I'll go to
a surgeon yeah when you know somebody
you brother was a great one and he's a
mechanic you have a low matter you're
not gonna take him to represent you in
court even though nobody loves you like
him same thing my mother or my father
loved me the most but they're not the
expertise and they don't have the
wherewithal ask us color and all the
guidelines of allah subhanaw taala
and the more we abide by allah subhanaw
taala you would draw a protection and
listen from him John this is more
important probably than even a heart
surgery yes the whole wife the whole
quality of yet one one one final quote I
heard be his servant he'll be your slave
have you heard this yes and it's true
and it's true as true yeah okay thank
you very much people can visit you at
the lies about Muhammad calm yes you're
the author of the book yes and you have
your own website yeah we made a website
for the book the lies about Muhammad
calm itself where we have our blog and
and
Media it's all about the the whole issue
thank you very much thank you and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Dene show keeping the family
together this is something so important
in Islam because if you got broken homes
you got broken societies work hard to
get to know this beautiful way of life
know the roles and responsibilities that
Allah has bestowed upon you and live
them submit to them this is your test is
one thing saying you believe but then
are you going to follow it up with
action and when a calamity hits you want
to be patient and you want to do all the
good that Allah has told you to do
because it's a test and trial your whole
life from the womb to the tomb you don't
want to give up you don't want to give
up you want to stay with it all the way
to the end and you want to keep those
families together you want to bring
those children up in a healthy
environment so they can be a benefit to
society and what better way when husband
and wife are together staying together
working together so then they can
produce wonderful results so with that
said we hope that you've got to benefit
and we'll see you next time here on the
D show same time same channel peace be
unto you you have to pray as if
everything depends on a lot it does
but you must work everything depends on
you that's my point you see the same and
I don't like that I don't like us
sitting here what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
do you wait for all these people that
come to Islam
what are you waiting for what are we
waiting for right now when they're gonna
come they're gonna come to log on bring
these people lost upon the water put in
our hand the ability to do it now do
your job
I'm not alone I am NOT alone I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid